at the end of the 19th century David
Hilbert who was a famous mathematician
at the time listed 20 problems that he
thought were gonna direct the future of
20th century mathematics but one of them
helpers third problem was so easy that
Hilbert student solved it two years
after he posed it so that's the one I
want to explain today yeah I would call
it Hilbert's third problem but it's
maybe maybe let's call it the equity
composability problem if you have two
polygons p1 and p2 so no rules about
convex or concave no rules about convex
or concave all you need is a finite
number of straight lines which meet and
form a closed figure so here's two
polygons p1 and p2 and they have the
same area then you can cut off p1 with
finitely many straight lines and
rearrange the pieces to get p2 so here's
an example of a polygon which I've
already pre-cut it's a parallelogram and
here's how you can rearrange it into a
rectangle with the same area just move
this triangle over here so that was
pretty easy so the proof actually gives
you an algorithm for cutting up a
polygon and and decomposing it into
another one so a Hilbert's third
question which was in 1898 I think was
is the same thing true in three
dimensions so what do I mean by that I
mean if you have two polyhedra so
three-dimensional figures which are made
out of you know flat faces edges and
vertices and if they have the same
volume can you cut one up into pieces
with finitely many cuts and rearrange
the pieces to make the other I mean my
intuition would be yes it's because if
you put two polyhedra with the same
volume into like a bath they'll displace
the same amount of water so yeah so if
you were allowed to melt the polyhedra
you could definitely do it but if you're
only allowed to use straight cuts it
turns out you can't and this is what
dana proved and I think Hilbert probably
expected this so I think he probably
tried with the cube tried to cut it up
into pieces and rearrange it into a
tetrahedron so that's a figure with four
faces all Butcher triangles which are
the same and he couldn't do it and so
the actual question was can you cut up a
cube with finitely many knife cuts and
rearrange the pieces to get a
tetrahedron and Dana ended up proving
that you can't do that you can't do it
you can't do it what changes between 2
and 3 dimensions that suddenly makes it
impossible yeah so so I can explain at
least the idea behind Dana's proof Dane
was the student of Hilbert and it was
his thesis problem to solve helpers
third
one of the greatest theses of all time
and so so what was his idea
well his idea was that well let's say
you have two polygons which have a
different area
why can't you cut one up and and
rearrange it to the other well the area
is invariant under this action of
cutting it and then moving the pieces
around the area doesn't change so Dane's
idea was that you should find some
invariant of a polyhedron that doesn't
change when you cut it up and move the
pieces around and then he wanted to
compute that invariant for the cube and
for the tetrahedron and see if they're
different so what that means is that you
know no matter how you take the cube cut
it up and move the pieces around if
these invariants are different you can't
get a tetrahedron in that way the deal
break has a thing that in the top chain
the obstruction yeah to move changing
one piece and one one polyhedron into
another polyhedron what was it I'll tell
you it's kind of its kind of complicated
so so we should maybe we should build up
to it let's prove this 18:33 theorem so
this is equity composability for
polygons all right so there are several
steps so what's the goal let me first
make the problem a little bit easier
let's try to cut up a polygon of area a
so it could be five and rearrange the
pieces into a one by a rectangle and I
claim that's enough why is that it's
because cutting something up and
rearranging the pieces is a reversible
operation so if you have a polygon of
area a you can make it into a one by a
rectangle and another polygon a barrier
a you can make it into the same one by a
rectangle and then well how do you get
from your first polygon to your second
one you just pass through the one by a
rectangle that you are able to make both
of them into so it's enough to do this
so we can assume one of P 1 and P 2 is
just a rectangle what's the first step
it's easy you just cut it into triangles
step two is a little trickier we're
gonna turn triangles into parallelograms
all right so we have our triangle what
do we do we take the midpoints of these
two sides we draw the line through them
so that this has the same length as this
and then well we just move this triangle
over here so here's a triangle and now
you can cut it up and turn it into a
parallelogram so any triangle can be
parallel but parallelogram eyes
yeah that's exactly right all right now
we're gonna turn there Lowell grams into
rectangles so here what do you do you
just drop a perpendicular like this and
then move this triangle over here here's
my parallelogram and I'm gonna turn it
into a rectangle that was easy alright
so now we have some rectangle which has
the same area as our original polygon
well we do this for every triangle we
got then we get a bunch of rectangles
and now we're gonna make it into a one
by a rectangle and so here's some
rectangle and what we do is we measure
out a distance one let's say one inch or
so on the bottom and draw a rectangle
with the same area now we connect these
two vertices and it turns out that the
triangle ABC is the same it's congruent
to the triangle d e f so we can start by
moving this triangle and just sliding it
down here now there's a little bit left
over it's these two triangles and it
turns out they're also the same it turns
out the triangle a d G it's the same as
the triangle C F H how do we cut this
rectangle up into this one which has the
desired property to one by the area
rectangle just move this triangle over
here and this triangle over here okay
and that finishes the proof we first cut
into triangles then we cut into
telegrams then we cut into rectangles
then we've had a special rectangles
and then we undo all of that to get into
the other polygon that we wanted to aim
at at the beginning cool okay so so why
did this work it worked because we had
this one invariant that we knew to
search for the area where we were gonna
search for a one by a rectangle and it
turns out that there's a secret hidden
invariant in three dimensions that will
stop us from running this algorithm all
right so let's let's see what Dane did
so what he wanted to do is he wanted to
take a cube and a tetrahedron which have
the same volume and he wanted to show
you couldn't cut up this up in any way
with a finite number of slices rearrange
the pieces to get this one so he had to
come up with some way of distinguishing
the two something that is different
about these guys
it doesn't change when you cut them up
and rearrange the pieces Daniel you're
saying he wanted to show you couldn't do
it that's right
wouldn't he rather have shown you could
do it did he already know he probably
tried I mean yeah so why do you
conjecture something's impossible you
like to try really hard and try really
hard and you just fail and you get
really frustrated and you're like I'm
gonna prove this can be done and in
Danes case he was able to do it so
here's the basic observation so let's
zoom in on some edge of a polyhedron and
there's two invariants of this edge you
can look at you can look at the length
so L is the length of an edge and
there's another invariant which I'll
call theta that's the dihedral angles
it's the angle it takes to get from this
face to this one so it's the angle swept
out by my hands I moved from one face to
the other it's the angle it takes to get
from this face to this one so that's
some angle between 0 and 2pi so what's
the observation the observation is
there's two ways to cut so one is you
can cut like this so you can cut with a
plane that kind of passes through the
edge it cuts this edge in half right it
changes the length but it leaves the
dihedral angle the same right and the
lengths of the two edges you get are the
they sum to the original length so if
you cut let's say vertically you get L 1
theta + L 2 theta so the two lengths of
these two pieces L 1 and that's L 2 the
Thetas are the same and L 1 plus L 2 is
the original length right so the other
thing you can do is cut along the edge
so the other thing you can do is cut
like this and then you get well two
edges there on these two pieces they
have the same length and
angles some together so you get L theta
one and L theta two and here the theta
one plus theta two is the original theta
so the two dihedral angles add together
to give you what you started with and so
dance idea was to stare at this and just
make it into an invariant in the most
brutal way possible so how did he do it
so here's the invariant so you take the
sum of the following symbols li tensor
theta I we're here this run's over the
edges of the polyhedron so what you do
is you take the length of each edge and
the angle at each edge and write down
just this sum which is right now just a
sum of symbols it doesn't mean anything
so let's figure out what it means that's
right it doesn't whoa
so we're sort of we're formally
multiplying them and then we're adding
these symbols together so let me let me
say what where this lives
so this lives in something which is
called the real numbers ten surd with
real numbers mod 2pi so let me explain
what this set is
that's right yeah
so let's say what this is it's an
element of this thing this weird object
is just a sum a 1 tensor V 1 plus a 2
tensor B 2 these are just symbols so far
all the way up to am tensor BM for some
N or these AI and bi are just real
numbers but we say two symbols like this
are the same if certain rules are
satisfied so what rules well first of
all a tensor B is the same as a tensor b
plus 2pi what is this expressing it's
just expressing that if you take an
angle and you add 2 pi to it you get the
same angle all right now we have some
other rules we say that a 1 tensor B
plus a 2 tensor B is the same as a 1
plus a 2 tensor B so you're allowed to
add on the left if the B's on the right
are the same so what does this express
it expresses that if you've two theta S
which are the same if you cut you can
add two lengths
that's just expressing this alright
there's one more rule it's just the same
thing on the other side so it says that
if you have a
ten sir v1 plus a tensor v2 that's the
same as a tensor b1 plus b2 and that's
just expressing this rule so this is
just a set of symbols which are allowed
to add and subtract but they follow some
funny rules when you do that and Danes
invariance is this object inside this
set and he's saying well no matter how
you cut off your shape when you compute
this invariant you get the same thing in
this set that's called the deign
invariant I'm not gonna pretend to
totally understand it but I believe you
what's wrong with having an invariant
though why does that mean I can't just
you know be strategic and make millions
of cuts and still be able to build these
thing now so the point of this invariant
is that it doesn't change when you make
a cut right you get more edges and you
get more angles but because of these
rules over here and equivalently these
rules over here the invariant in the set
just doesn't change so now what you have
to do is give into a polyhedron you have
to compute this invariant and sometimes
they're different right the Danes
observation showed that the invariant of
the cube is not the same as the
invariant of the tetrahedron so this
invariant is almost like like a
fingerprint or DNA that's exactly right
unique to the polyhedron yeah so so it
turns out and Dane didn't know this but
it was proven about 30 years later that
if you know the volume of a polyhedron
and you know the Dane invariant then
that determines the polyhedron up to
this operation of cutting and moving the
pieces around so in fact it's true that
if you have two polyhedra with the same
volume and the same deign invariant then
you can cut one up and get the other one
by rearranging the pieces but here Dane
what Dane did is just showed that if you
have two polyhedra with different
invariants you just can't do that you're
stuck there's no way you can change the
danger because once you've got that Dane
invariant you're stuck with it for life
that's right
yeah there's nothing you can do at least
with this operation of cutting with a
knife and moving the pieces around the
changes that invariant that's why it's
called an invariant what's the daily
invariant of a cube like yes we can do
or the Denver end of a cube that's a
good example so let's let's do the cube
so luckily all the edges are the same
we only have to compute with one edge so
let's say we have a cube of side length
one and then what do we have to do we
have to compute the angle well that's
just ninety degrees or PI over two so
for each edge contributes one tensor PI
over two and then how many edges are
there one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve and well
because of this rule that if the second
guys are the same we can add the first
guys this is just the same as twelve
tensor PI over two if you'd like that's
the data invariant of the cube now the
tetrahedron is a little harder while you
compute this angle which I'll just call
theta a little bit of a pain to compute
it so I won't do it here
you have to compute what side length
gives you a volume of one so let's call
it L and how many edges are there
there's one two three four five six so
you get six times L tensor theta and
once you compute what these actually are
you'll see that it isn't the same as
this so if I gave you a cube and said
turn this into a tetrahedra yeah you're
gonna say yeah I can do that
but unfortunately I'm gonna have to
change this volume no unfortunately you
have to do but the volume and the being
invariant because of course the volume
doesn't change when you cut and move
things around either so those are
exactly the two invariants of a
polyhedron the volume and the data
invariant Dane's big contribution was to
discover that this is there is the
second one nobody knew that before how
come I can do what I melt them yeah
that's a good question that's because
melting them doesn't change the volume
right but it does change this invariant
you've destroyed all the edges so how
would you even compute the data variant
in fact it turns out in higher
dimensions there are also even more
invariants we don't know what they are
in general so that's an open problem if
you want to think about I don't know 12
dimensional polyhedra and one you can
cut one up and get the other one it's
actually a really beautiful and exciting
part of mathematics there's a little bit
of complicated mathematics there are
that's right but I can still appreciate
what Dane did the cleverness of it that
he found that he realized those edges
were the problem yeah it was clear well
I think the really amazing thing is he
knew well the lengths of the edges don't
stay the same and the dihedral angles
don't stay the same when you cut things
up but there's some funny way of
combining
them all together that does stay the
same that's really the miracle of the
data in Berrien
clever yeah good thesis yeah a bit there
was no no no questioning about giving
him his doctorate yeah I mean he went on
to do a lot of amazing stuff than the
rest of mathematics too but yeah this is
an amazing start because the hotel's
full but the managers clever and here's
what he does he shifts the person in
room 1 to room 2 and the person in room
2 to room 3 and the person in room 3 to
room 4 and so on
everyone gets shifted forward one room
because I didn't do many rooms you never
run out of rooms to put people in